hello everyone this game was played in
1958 between Bobby Fischer and Samuel
Reshevsky and although this is a very
short game it's worth noticing that
similar Russian ski was a magnificent
player he had a very long chest career
and in this career he played against the
11 world champions and of those 11 he
defeated seven of them including
champions like Lasker kappa blanka and
alexander alekhine so it's it's really
hard to imagine that he could fall for a
trap like this but although you can find
this game on the Internet as Bobby Bobby
Fischer strap or Bobby strap after this
game Bobby actually said he just read
about this strap and all the Russian
magazine from the 50s and yeah Bobby
also said that somewhere around 1950s he
considered Samuel Reshevsky to be the
strongest player in the world so let's
see this short game between these two
great rivals Bobby is white and he plays
efore Reshevsky is black he goes c5 this
is solely on defense
Knight to f3 knight c6 d4c takes d4
Knight takes d4 and rg6 accelerated
dragon and I see 3 Bobby goes for the
knight of variation not for the C for
the maroc C binder which is more popular
nowadays Bishop to g7 Bishop to e3 90 to
f6 and here Fischer plays Bishop to c4
his signature move and black castles and
black is also setting a trap here he's
hoping for white to play f3 and organize
an attack with Queen d2 with Bishop h6
but this would be a this would be a
blunder
because Queen to b6 is a very very very
ugly move for white as he is attacking
the b2 pawn and after white protected
somehow
Bishop to b3 now black has this resource
of playing Knight takes on e4 and this
is a at least an equal position for
black which Fisher doesn't allow of
course so in this position Fisher plays
another another of his signature moves
Bishop to b3 and this is a tricky move
this is the position that's called
bobbies trap he's inviting black to play
Knight to a5 and try and exchange this
stronger light squared Bishop which for
no reason Samuel Reshevsky plays and
falls for the trap he plays Knight to a5
and this is what happens next
Bobby plays d5 and now if Reshevsky
captures on b3 rather then he simply
loses a piece after he takes f6 and I
take some b1 okay we can just play it
here and now this is Knight is trapped
because black has to capture the pawn on
g7 so after E 5 if the night goes on h5
then simply g4 and the knight is
captured so there was only one place for
the night to go and that's Knight to e7
but this is a very big blunder as
Fischer plays Bishop takes on f7 and in
here black can easily resign which
Rachelle's he probably saw but as I said
that we were they were great rivals and
he didn't want to allow Fischer to get
this miniature game accomplished
so yeah like I said you could resign
here but he played the rook takes on f7
and here Fischer plays Knight II 6 and
traps the black queen there is no place
for a black queen to go and again this
is another position where Reshevsky
could have just resigned but he decided
to capture and give up his queen
and he played a couple more moves and
only after a couple of more moves he
resigned but it's interesting what
happens if King captures on f7 if King
captures on f7 then again 96 trapping
the Queen but now the King can capture
here King takes an e6 but this is even
worse as black is getting checkmated
Queen to d5 check King goes to a5g4
check King captures rook the g1 check
came to h4 Quinta efore check and after
king gage 520 g4 checkmate a couple more
moves are possible for black but they
all lead to checkmate so doesn't really
matter what black plays so yeah this is
the position and this is move number
move number 7 where Bobby played Bishop
to b3 so this great Grandmaster Samuel
Reshevsky makes such a huge blunder and
move 8 and plays Knight to a5 and well
the rest is history so yeah that's the
game I hope you enjoyed it and see you
soon